um okay so before I giving thanks I want
to tell you a story of myself ten years
ago I downloaded when I was 14 and I
downloaded a pirated editing software on
the internet in china and i use it and i
download a lot of footage from internet
and some pictures of a good-looking
actors and put them together and that
was my first time doing visual
storytelling and five years ago I went
to Taiwan as exchange student at learn
journalism there and my professor said
to me okay you were doing journalism and
you're doing film so why don't you do
documentary so three years ago I got
accepted by nyu news and documentary
program and my classmate is my my
closets just like my first family in US
and they helped me with my shooting
editing help me with my English help me
to clean myself when I got drunk at
parties that's embarrassing no Club and
so two years ago I pitch a story about
North Korean defectors I went to North
Korea and i did sorry but during the
filming I found my the only source i got
was in jail so i stopped the story and i
cry for a lot of time I started to
question myself should I really do this
documentary thing so fortunately i met
fairy who is the subject of my film
fairy tales and i did a story on crew so
one month ago I still hadn't heard
anything from Academy so I thought okay
I'll just go to Taiwan for a trip so I
booked the ticket but few days later I
heard from Sean that I get this award so
I canceled the flight and now I'm
standing here giving this speech so I
really want to thank all of those who
accompanied with me during this journey
and make my journey full of surprises I
want to thank Marshall rock my professor
at NYU in all my my
you classmates I want to thank my crew
members especially my producer k Jon boy
who always being there very tolerant
because I really had that temper when I
was editing and yeah I want to thank my
family who so far has very little idea
of what i'm doing now because they don't
know anything about independent film the
what they felt know about is film is
about Hollywood Academy Awards so thanks
to Academy giving me this award that I
can prove to my parents what your
daughter's doing it's about Academy
Awards ok so thanks to all of you and
documentary is not an easy thing for
Chinese female filmmakers so I feel very
fortunate to be a storyteller in such a
shifting age in China where a lot of
amazing stories happen thank you very
much